hello I'm Rodrigo bond over my
presentation is titled disposable
visualization with Mathematica
hello my name is Rodrigo Vonda thank you
for coming to my talk I realized that a
lot of the things that you see and the
other talks is about you know death in
math and Mathematica or Wolfram language
that's not what my intention here and
also realize that the ultimate intention
of what I'm actually trying to do is to
promote Mathematica which I don't think
I need to do that here because most of
you I assume our users of Mathematica
but nonetheless I wanted to sort of
trace back in before I came to
Mathematica and then now that I'm in
Mathematica and and this is an idea that
I've been having for a while now about
the disposable visualizations so there's
the abstract which is you know not to
read but let me see if I can make this
one a little bit bigger so 200 not too
big
I think 150 okay so the idea of weight
with the what I wanted to to trace is
that we sometimes you know we try to
make sense of the world and we do that
through our eyes for census and we try
to do many things for this and try to
acquire knowledge about our world we use
some of the things that we use a lot not
now I know that not everybody but many
you actually use visualization we use
that visualization so that we can you
know understand what's going on in a
system and most of the time the
isolation is really triggers is the the
main target is yourself is the creator
of the other visualization and sometimes
you know some other people may actually
understand or get about the same the
same idea with this now when we use the
visualizations in
we create all this we we gain insight
and then we to me that's the whole
purpose of visualization is that you are
able to gain inside of whatever its
underlying in the system so what happens
though is that when you create a
visualization you realize that you you
want to to show that to other people and
and this has been you know some
something you want others to actually be
able to do that and to understand the
same thing that you understand but
sometimes we do not connect at the same
level and we end up moving ourselves
away from our area of research into the
area of creating visualizations and now
we shift and then instead of continuing
working of whatever we're interested in
we're now working in the visualization
and trying to make it better and better
so that others will understand which
actually moves us away from what we are
supposed to be doing so I thought that
instead of doing that you know we should
not feel compelled to create this
visualization if the only purpose is to
understand a system of a process you
know we should not be making better and
better for others we should make him
better so that we understand so that
then later on we can use that knowledge
to to really perform something in our
systems so those are the visualizations
that I call this possible visualization
know I talked to somebody here that they
actually told me they looked at me said
disposable you know if it felt like bad
and in what I tried to say was it's not
necessarily disposable but it may be
also called personal you know so it is a
visualization for me and it speaks to me
and I might be able to see something in
that maybe nobody else will so it
doesn't matter I use it and then I
understand that
so this disposable visualizations can be
called personal visualizations and they
may be may be enhanced
and then other people might be able to
understand so how is it that I can come
came to this well let me give you some
examples at NASA I was a long time ago I
was a graduate research assistant I was
implementing a fault-tolerant motek
computer operating system you know for
for NASA Langley and the implementation
about testing multiple computers and
they will be talking to each other I
brought that in assembly language and as
I progressed and the implementation you
know I realized that I had no idea how
these multiple computers were actually
working and I was supposed to be you
know doing all this but I didn't know
that so I needed to visualize the
overall system and not just a single
computer and what I did is I develop a
simple log system that will report
important events in the system and I use
visualization idea taken from digital
analyzers am my undergraduate was in
electronics engineering so I looked at a
dot and said now I'm gonna develop
something like that I actually wrote it
and qbasic anybody ever heard of us you
know don't you basic I guess Bruce Priss
you know he probably heard that so the
the idea that I developed with that you
know this this step was not really
required you know and in terms of the
whatever I was doing I needed it for me
I knew I wanted to know that whatever I
was doing was actually happening in
there was something going on inside so I
demonstrated a project to the research
group and I also show the visualization
tools and other bonus contrary to what I
am proposing that particular
visualization was not a personal
visualization so in this talk you know
the you know this is not the thing that
I'm trying to do in this store but the
tool was revealing to the principal
investigators when they saw it so in
five minutes in looking at the
visualization they are the events of the
operating system they realized that they
were going in the wrong direction and
the research they have you know the use
transition matrices the use actual Petri
Nets is anybody knows about Petri Nets
they use those matrices to analyze the
system you know prime you know to what I
joined the group
and then they looked at that and they
said well I think this visualization is
worth the time to invest and I said okay
so that became a complete part of the
other other research but that one hit a
point with other people but I was
originally was just for me it was just
you know they actually one of the
investigators called the ticker tape you
know because it looks like stock now
later on I was in business and and I was
working for a corporation and I
developed all this software for daily
operations they did from from billing
and payroll and you know everything that
they needed I I developed for them so
they printed long reports and when
weekly you know all their accounts
payable I know that this is probably
boring for all of you but you know the
businesses need the money so they
printed all these invoices and they
there were thick reports every week and
they were handling the accounts
receivable one by one so I come out for
that ID I said this is terrible and then
in in it all comes to just a bunch of
numbers and I know that you say why did
they do that but this is back in the 90s
so I developed a visualization of that I
could not only visualize every client
every invoice but I could sir
conglomerate so that and aggregations of
that and I could actually look at the
entire health of the company but just
looking at that visualization you see on
the screen I call the ring tuple because
it's like a ring but it was several
rings so it's a tuple know in in in turn
out to be that that time that it was
sort of okay so after I finished in this
company you know I got the invitation to
go on teach and I actually used it with
students students sort of understood
that they got it can actually be you so
many other things and and by the way I
wrote
dollie Java 3d I doubted any of you ever
used Java 3d it's actually a different
product you know it didn't last too long
but I used that it took me a long time
you know to really make it work etc so I
decided to take it to a visualization
conference and they looked at it and
they asked me if I had tested it with
people and I had done these so that
thought then I realized that this was no
longer personal I now I needed to test
it with many other people so and I said
oh my god it's so much time that I used
on this you know because I had to work
on this and I had to to do all the
manipulations etc even though on the
underlying system is a sort of a series
of vectors but I needed to do the 3d
which is you know the visualization so
that was not very good anyway in
cellular automata so as I met you know
Stephen Wolfram and I became interested
in Sarah tomatoes you know I'm a first
part it was actually using the
visualization that I showed you before
according to pool and I started doing
all these things in in in reality you
know I I started looking at how the
cellular automata is it's working in how
they you know I tried to understand how
because I didn't know that I even
presented a poster in one of the
conferences so I wasn't a train to New
York City when it actually hit me and I
was able to do you know to see the
visualization I said maybe this is a way
to do that now this is a visualization
that most nobody has seen I mean the
most you know people have not seen this
is the visualization that I did what I
was in the train and to me it is poke
tones a lot it was a lot of stuff I was
saying what you see in there is it as
there are eight different points and
each one of those eight difference is
one of the state of the three bits that
are
that are defined in the cellular
automata you have the the central cell
and the two and other so if you have
that as eight points the ones on the top
are the ones that the central cell is
one the ones in the bottom they are zero
now I did this just as a matter of
understanding I wanted to have a better
idea how that was working so I created
it I wrote it in Mathematica and then of
course with a line of code I was able to
then just do all 256 and they are
actually ordered in a way that that this
particular visualization allow me to
look into this and then I wrote a paper
as in a complex systems in a in a
different way of looking at the cellular
some other rules that allows me to do
this kind of ordering so that I could I
could see it in here and then you just I
started to see certain areas within the
space but this was one line of code at
the end so it became to me something
that I can just dispose off that was
personal and I didn't have to make it so
that other people who had to see it so I
continued you know working with
something like that and I was interested
in the local mark of change of this and
then I use again the three bits and then
it had eight states you know similar to
what you had before and this is the
entire space where I couldn't see it all
of it but you can see that there are
areas and in here let me see if I could
the one oh the link is the probability
of jumping from one state to another you
know there's a Markov chains so the
interesting thing for me was that if you
see here right in the middle you see how
this these rules are similar to each
other so they're ordering of the rules
was actually appropriate for these
actually show you know side-by-side or
look at these other rules over here they
are similar in terms of their local
Markov chain 30 is right here and 86 is
down here which is if you see this just
a there's a manipulation of that you
know I said rotation and then you see it
this is symmetrical across and then you
see it over here the same thing it is
symmetrical over here this is 110 and
this is the 124 which is spiral at the
same class that this one over here is
the other one
193 or 137 and you can see that you know
you can see certain things certain
characteristics of that so look at this
one over here it's almost like this one
except that there is just an anomaly
that made it class 3 made it completely
go random so I can started looking at
all these things again very personal but
this allow me to again in one line after
I just wrote the the the little
visualization of the cellular automata
to be able to see the entire the entire
set so the interesting thing with this
is as a spin-off for this I actually
came across another problem that's a
math problem which is this is the one
yes it has to do with monotone boolean
functions is anybody knows about
monotone boring functions they are
actually very special functions for
certain things they're actually the
number of monotone boolean functions
giving a very lumber of variables is the
data King numbers so it's 2/3 620 168
7581 etc so I became interested in that
for reasons that I saw in there and I
started investigating into something
like that and let me let me show you
something that I quickly did with that
when I did that actually presented this
here in 2006 and then I in fact because
of the visualization I saw that there
was an interesting way that the main the
the lattices will
from one to another this is part of the
sequence and the way that this is
computed is very involved if we have
only computed eight numbers but I was
able to find a way to go from one
lattice to the next one directly and as
I said this was the spin-off of the work
that I was doing so it allowed me to
move into other areas just for the
simple visualization and I actually I
created a sub direct product for those
of you that know about you know SIL
direct products of lattices so going
beyond all that two years ago for the
student I also came out for the
probabilistic cellular automata that has
all kinds of him interest in
characteristics and now I'm also let me
see I'm working something that I work a
presented last year which was an
exploration of the spaces and let me
show you something real quick in here
like something like this that I can I
can go into not only the ECA you know
which is the elementary scalar Tomita
256 I can this is actually mapping
inside the bigger space the four billion
rule space and then I can take a little
piece of that this is 124 oh excuse me
110 but this is mapped to the higher and
into the higher space and I can see in
the neighbors there are many of those
that look similar you know this is
something that I have not seen anybody
else doing doing this this kind of
mapping so I was able to do something
like that and what am I here
so I've demonstrated all those things
those are available under the website
etc so in conclusion and I wanted to
show a bit more but I was robbed of a
little bit of a time at the beginning so
but if you use visualizations of any
kind
you should not despair if others do not
and what you are actually trying to show
we happen to me a lot
perhaps the visualization suggest for
you
personal or disposable or as a colleague
I met during discomfort called it
ephemeral and so we make models that we
see around us you know around us in
order to understand the world so let us
create a myriad of visualizations that
will help us unveil the mysteries of the
world remember your visualizations may
just be scaffolding for discovery and
that's what I wanted to show and I think
I have time for questions right yes yes
yes what was that one oh yeah that one
sorry this one
they are three-dimensional they are this
is this one this is real 30 all right
correct yes they actually show
transition yes so this this is the way
this over here are zero they are this
this the central cell is zero when it's
blue it is actually transitioning to one
when they is they're red they transition
they stay they stay in zero yes yes
let's see again no that's what helped me
understand and actually these drove the
papers that I later on where I composed
the rule into two primitive primitive
zero primitive one and this is
extensible to any other you know if we
have more three I have three primitives
and the interesting thing is that for
instance if you if you look at other the
all the boolean functions of the ECA you
know 256 I can show those and generate
them with with Mathematica using only 16
of those because all those 16 system
actually expresses every one of the of
the two primitives so if I do a product
of them I can actually generate or 256
so that was the the basic idea but it's
it moves into the other states of well
it moves into color no three colors four
colors etc you also you always have the
number of colors decays the number of
primitives
yes my student a couple years ago this
is what we did no no this one this is
what we did in and he discovered for
instance when he actually did that in
terms of feature not necessarily in the
rule but he found those that those eight
you know they are related you know
they're not the same class but they are
related as you can see and there is a
complement of those in fact this the
signatures of the of these clusters
you know it's what they take this in
that's what allows us to do
probabilistic cellular automata you know
which actually combines the features of
all those into into one and
unfortunately I don't have it here but
two days ago on Wednesday I was showing
in the hololens because i have this in
3d that you can actually go in and see
that and then you can you can see the
different clusters and how those
generate the the probabilistic cellular
automata and the evolution for that he
you actually used sometimes on analyze
used in the image using fast fourier
transform for comparisons some other
times just did a brute force we were
just exploring the space now when you
when if you if you look at the space
they are joined by there is a distance
it is a difference of one bit between
each one of those and that's how he was
able to navigate you know one at a time
so he wouldn't just go into everyday the
entire space because there is an order
and this in fact the lattice in i think
four dimensions but yeah yeah we will
look at some some of those things
all right thank you very much
[Applause]